stupid corporate decisions number one
HBO had the opportunity to air the
walking dead but past apparently they
thought it was too violent
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where we always
recommend the DoubleTap so let's talk
The Walking Dead in a world where
zombies are everywhere AMC's The Walking
Dead is the big boy on the playground
the most popular piece of zombie related
media in the last decade except not
they're not zombies they're walkers
walking or biters but I always thought
that was weird but in researching this
episode I found that according to the
series creator Walking Dead takes place
in a universe where the concept of
zombies doesn't exist in the pop-culture
lexicon hence the characters having to
learn about things like attacking the
brain well it's good for them I guess it
means they live in a universe where Eva
Bowles House of the Dead doesn't exist
on the flip side though their insistence
on calling them walkers now forces me to
sarcastically replace all zombie
pictures throughout this episode with
pictures of tennis ball Laden nursing
home equipment and chuck norris Texas
Ranger the original Walker but there's
always been one other thing that's
bothered me since early on in the show
and no it's not the way rick pronounces
things anything anything everything or
coral I mean a Carl it's the fact that
by the end of season 1 all of our main
characters are killing machines deadly
warriors who are always on high alert
because if they let their guard down for
a second they could be mincemeat for
some zombified or biter a fight creature
they've survived this long because well
survival is their talents but despite
all of this zombies still somehow are
able to sneak up on them regularly that
is absurd these are zombies not Solid
Snake but it did get me thinking our
heroes can't seriously be snuck up on
that often can they how can they be so
simultaneously badass yet still get into
these absurd situations with walkers
that move at a snail's pace nicking up
and surprising them is it just some lazy
writing and easy way to create tension
where realistically there probably
shouldn't be any probably yes but here
on film theory we try to explain away
those logical inconsistencies with the
help of science and today loyal
theorists I think there's
something very wrong with our lovable
ragtag motley crew of survivors
something with a perfectly sound
scientific explanation I think they're
all losing their hearing no I get it
that's a bit of a weird thing to say
right hearing loss well first let me
explain how noise induced hearing loss
works it should come as no surprise but
very loud sounds can damage the internal
workings of the ear sound is measured in
decibels and generally speaking anything
below 75 decibels is safe to hear pretty
much constantly however once you start
getting above 85 decibels you get into
the range where the sound you hear can
potentially damage one's hearing and
cause permanent hearing loss once you
get over 120 decibels you actually start
to feel pain the louder the sound the
shorter amount of time it takes to do
the damage now that 85 decibel threshold
of danger might sound like it's a really
high number but it's not a normal
conversation is usually around 60
decibels heavy city traffic is 85 larga
players reaction to a staff jump-scare
probably around a hundred depending on
the volume of your headphones a passing
motorcycle a concert your mp3 player at
max volume all well above 85 and the
decibel recording system is weighted in
a pretty unique way so that in that last
example an iPod turned up all the way
actually averages at roughly 105
decibels which would be a hundred times
more intense than a sound at 85 decibels
so that's all well and good but how does
it all work well when a noise travels
into the ear it vibrates the eardrum and
several tiny bones which amplify the
sound as it enters the inner ear
otherwise known as the cochlea here
small hairs are attached to nerve cells
these hairs ride the waves of these
vibrations creating electrical signals
that travel from our auditory nerves
into the brain we are then able to
translate the signals and to sound we
can recognize and understand the sheer
force of the vibrations created by
sounds louder than 85 dB you run the
risk of destroying these little hairs
and once they're damaged or destroyed
they don't grow back the hearing loss is
permanent so what does any of this have
to do with the walking dead well
consider this guns are loud incredibly
loud and the survivors often shoot them
in positions where the gums are right
next to their ears
oftentimes in firing squad formation or
next to their faces just watch a Rick
Grimes kill compilation it's incredible
up through March of this year Rick alone
had killed 154 themes throughout the
five seasons humans and walkers alight
and the vast vast majority of those are
gun kills with Rick firing wildly into
crowds of zombies like it's left 4 dead
so those are bad enough but then there
are other creative kills where the gun
is right up against the ear like in
season 2 when Rick gets stuck under two
Walker's he just killed and has to do
this cool move where he shoots a walker
through the mouth of another Walker the
gun is inches from his ear they actually
play with the idea of the sound of guns
hurting your ears in season 4 when Rick
head butts a man holding a gun to his
head
the man fires the gun by accident right
next to Rick's ear and Rick ears ringing
for several seconds but this I think is
my favorite where Rick literally turns
his ear into the gun before he shoots it
look Andrew Lincoln
I get it I know you're conveying some
painful emotions here but your character
is gonna be dealing with some painful
emotional ear damage when you do that
again there are more instances of this
than would be interesting to count in
this video but you can already start to
see how the survivors are putting their
hearing in danger but just how far gone
are they let's find out our favorite
sheriff turned Walker Slayers gun of
choice is the Colt Python 357 Magnum
which when shot has been measured to be
as loud as 164 decibels just to give you
a frame of reference that's over a
hundred times more powerful than a jet
engine which is rated at 140 DB a
hundred times and he's firing this thing
off like it's Christmas
there are countless different types of
9-millimeter pistols used in the show
from Glocks to lady Smith's to browning
high powers all of which measure in the
hundred and sixty DB range shotguns are
also a frequent weapon of choice
including several different types of 12
and 20 gauge varieties clocking in at
150 decibels or so Gayle's 308 remington
700 156 DB long story short just looking
at these numbers we can see that all of
them get above both of the threshold of
danger and the threshold of pain so you
know we're dealing with some pretty
powerful sound and it gets worse
a lot of the time the survivors are
shooting in small echoey enclosed spaces
I mean they spent two entire seasons and
had countless firefights in a prison as
early as Episode one
Rick gets stuck under a tank and kills
off five walkers and this makes things
much much worse for them you see sound
acts as a wave and can bounce off of
walls creating echoes that's why I
record these episodes in my closet the
clothes absorb sound so it sounds like
I'm right up against you and talking
into your ear but without any padding to
absorb the sound it bounces until it
eventually dissipates with each bounce
those tiny hairs in your ears are
getting smacked with another way and we
are dealing with sounds as loud as
gunshots each of those waves is creating
huge amounts of damage sure would have
sound echoes it generally tends to
become about 40% weaker but at this high
of DB level in such close proximity to
your ears it's gonna be very very bad
for our survivors hearing like say that
tank I mentioned it's very likely that
Rick would have had his hearing
permanently damaged in the first hours
of the series when he killed the walkers
under the tank and in the tank with him
sure they do show Rick in pain after the
encounter the sound of the gunshot
completely disorienting him but then
they promptly forget about this and have
him talking to walkie-talkie a couple
seconds later this is something that
happens time and time and time again on
this series and sound damage has a
cumulative effect
well one bad blast can have you lose
your hearing permanently see also Archer
and his tinnitus more often each
concussion your ear has to deal with
adds on to all the other ones that came
before meaning that with each shot each
creative kill the survivors are becoming
more and more deaf more and more
susceptible to a walker sneak attack now
I can already hear you saying
but matpat what about soldiers Aaron
firefights at least semi frequently but
they're not all deaf and yeah that's
true but there's the key difference the
military uses hearing protection allow
me to introduce you to the combat arms
earplug these things are pretty cool
with two sides that offer two different
types of protection the yellow sides
allow you to hear conversations but
protects slightly against high-pitched
banging and snapping well the brown
sides offer complete hearing protection
and even with this preventive action
there have been reports of hearing loss
or ringing in ears being a serious
problem for soldiers returning home from
war and it's not just from Iraq or
Afghanistan it's been a problem since
World War two so with the amount that
they shoot guns and how often the guns
are close to their faces most of the
survivors really are putting their lives
at risk it also explains why Rick has to
shout literally non-stop to find coral I
mean Carl but there's one more cool part
to this theory Daryl and Michonne since
they were introduced these characters
have been fan favorites mostly because
of their really cool weapons of choice
the crossbow and the katana but now you
have another reason to respect these
machines of Walker death not only are
they super effective and reusable
weapons but they're also practically
silent which means they're gonna be a
lot more effective in the series for a
lot longer
Daryl isn't deadly simply because of his
aim and tracking skills is because he's
protecting one of his most valuable
survival senses his hearing okay yeah
sure he rides around on a motorcycle
which is above the threshold of danger
but no one's perfect okay it opposed
pocalypse you got to do what you got to
do long story short with how much they
shoot guns and how often they're in
enclosed spaces while shooting I'm
surprised that any characters on the
show can hear anything anymore let alone
all the loud sputtering zombies that
seem to sneak up with them with
remarkable ease I guess the survivors of
The Walking Dead
should more accurately be called the
walking death but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut attention
anime fans today we're taking a poll
which series would you like to see
covered on a future episode of film
Theory Full Metal Alchemist or sword art
online click on one to choose to cast
your votes in the meantime though if you
watch The Walking Dead you must like
zombies if so check out my video on
history's most famous zombie
Frankenstein's monster and how dr.
Frankenstein could indeed bring the dead
back to life using modern science by
clicking right here and really that's
about it so now if you'll excuse me I've
gotta go gotta go
work on my next theory II yeah we're
tackling that one get ready